- We had breakdowns in the system.
We ended up on the front page
of the Wall Street Journal.
Find every excuse to have a party.
So I think innovation is everywhere.
I think it's in the structure
of your organization.
You've got to be over here with the needle
to get the needle here.
Somebody's out there waiting to pluck you.
Or anyone in the world
and say, "I'm dreaming.
"Please, I'm not going to
make any numbers for a while."
People today are just better.
You grow from the reflected
glory of your people.
Never do what the assignment is.
Do more than that.
Thousands of people are walking around
frightened to death about
what's going to happen.
- He's retired American
business executive,
author and chemical engineer.
- He was chairman and
CEO of General Electric.
- Between 1981 and 2001.
- During his tenure at GE,
the company's value rose 4000%.
- He's Jack Welch, and here's
his top 10 rules for success.
- Well, I was tumultuous
in the early career.
I was totally impetuous.
I've always had a stamina,
so that's a weakness from
the beginning to the end,
I think that'll be there.
I think if I,
I made mistakes on deals.
I'd openly admit it.
I'd walk around talking about it.
If I can make this big a dopey move,
anybody can make a move.
Don't be paralyzed.
I made lots of mistakes on people.
I hired people, in the early days,
I hired almost always on
resumes and slickness,
which is probably inversely
proportional to talent.
(audience laughs)
So I did a number of these things
on a fairly frequent basis.
But I talked about it.
I think the thing is, talking about
what your mistakes are helps
an organization enormously.
It allows them to feel free to make them.
I mean, I bought an investment banking.
No one could make a
mistake bigger than that.
Boo boos that we had, we
didn't have to run ads,
we had breakdowns in the system,
we ended up on the front page
of the Wall Street Journal
17 times in 14 months,
the right hand column, being called dopes.
That's not fun.
And we went through that because
it was a cultural error
that I personally made.
And I owned up to it, talked
to everybody about it.
A boss's entire job is to get
the combined intellect of his team
to be raised to a new level,
and to instill spirit,
find every way to celebrate.
Find every excuse to have a party.
Every little victory counts.
I mean, it is so,
if a boss can't energize,
if he or she can't excite and
make people want to be there,
they shouldn't have that title.
Well, I think people too often
think of innovation as going to the lab,
going off in a garage and
designing something new
and bringing it to market.
I think innovation's all around you.
You see or smell something
that somebody else is doing,
you adapt it to your place
and take it to new levels,
that's a breakthrough for your company.
And the process never stops.
And if you've got a company
that has a mentality inside
that is filled with searching
for a better idea every day,
not just as a slogan
but as a real concept,
you will have innovation
around you all the time.
Classic example,
we had an innovation by going to India.
We went to India in the late 80s.
And we went there to sell lots of products
to a billion people.
Well, 15 years later, we still haven't
reached a billion dollars in sales.
But we've got 41,000 employees
because we found intellect.
And we were the first people to go there
and build huge R and D
center, technology centers,
by using the intellect.
That's innovation.
Getting stuck in one
corner when bureaucracy
won't let you sell products,
but finding another answer, intellect,
and capitalizing on it.
So I think innovation is everywhere.
I think it's in the structure
of your organization.
I think it's in every
process you deal with.
It's just finding a bit better
way to do things every day.
And I think everything
has to be a closed loop.
You drive it with people, you
measure it with the people,
and then you go visit it.
And you go visit the progress.
Now, you'll get a lot of air
and nonsense when you go visit.
For example, in Six Sigma,
if the amount of savings
I was presented in the course of Six Sigma
were all added up, it
would have been larger
than the GDP of the United States.
(audience laughs)
I mean, the PowerPoint slides
can accumulate enormous depth.
So all these things
are hyped to an extend.
But they got to be.
You cannot make change
with rational behavior.
You cannot make change by,
"let's have quality program.
"Quality is good, everybody.
"Let's go at it.
"Let's make sure our customers
feel good with our quality."
You got to say, "no, our quality stinks.
"We've got to improve it dramatically."
Only the best people can be on it.
Half of our offices by the year 2005
will have been black belts in quality.
The stock options and the awards
are going to those leading the efforts.
And you've got to be a maniac about it.
To move it, you've got to
be over here with the needle
to gt the needle here.
If you are sitting there,
comfortable in what you're doing,
you can be sure,
with your nice awards of number one here,
number one here, number one Zagat,
and number one this one,
number one that one,
somebody's out there waiting to pluck you.
And you cant' get comfortable.
And at that rate of change,
if you start seeing stuff,
you've got to move.
The only job of a leader is
when you ran for Europe or anyone
in this room running businesses,
the only reason for having the job
is to make the right trade-offs,
between cutting costs, productivity,
efficiency and developing
new ideas and new products.
Anybody in the world, for example,
I love the EC.
He was always going to say,
"Oh, I hate these analysts presentations.
"Analysts are pressing me
for quarterly earnings,"
et cetera, et cetera.
Look, any jerk in the
world can squeeze all day
and say, "talk to me in
five years about my growth."
Or anyone in the world
can say, "I'm dreaming.
"Please, I'm not going to
make any numbers for a while."
You can squeeze or you can dream.
But a manger does both.
A leader does both.
You dream and you squeeze.
You eat while you dream.
And there's no getting around it.
That's why you're paid.
Any jerk can do one or the other.
(audience laughs)
But it's your job to
make those trade offs.
You've got to see everyone as a mentor.
Your whole crowd,
somebody who works for
you might be a mentor.
I remember when I became CEO,
I was not a great financial wizard.
I never did become a financial wizard.
But at least I had this
fellow who worked for me,
10 years my junior, 33
years when we made him CFO.
He basically dumped his brain into mine.
I live with him, as we
went through all this,
left side, right side, et cetera,
the balance sheet from A to Z,
and he was an enormously valuable person.
I've had people who were on my board
who were completely
committed to our success
who would challenge every
people appointment I would make,
who would ask me, "are you sure?"
I think the business
media is a great mentor.
You may laugh at that,
but I think Fortune, Business Week,
there's a business language.
I find the mentors read every story.
I can't understand why
somebody can be in business
and not read all those stories.
I think you'll learn what
strategies didn't work,
did work, some of the stories
aren't quite accurate,
some of them aren't true, so what?
You're constantly learning
the rhythm of business.
So education and teaching
is all around you.
As far as today, really,
we have an enormous cadre.
People today are just better
than they were before.
It's more competitive.
It's no longer, when you become CEO today,
it's no longer the coronation.
It's the beginning of a
new competitive career.
I remember in 1980 when I became CEO,
I would go to these meetings
where people would sit around,
and their briefing books
prepared by huge staff,
and they pontificated about
the economy and this other.
Nonsense stuff.
It meant nothing.
They're just mouthing words.
It was ridiculous.
Now, today, people are in short sleeves,
getting in there and doing it
because the global
competition is so tough.
I think building an
organization, building a team,
the idea that Jack Welch is the hero
of creating all this value is silly.
Getting great people in all these jobs,
it's the team that
makes this thing happen.
And so building a team
is your strongest suit.
And you've got to love your team.
You've got to want your
team to be promoted.
And when you're coming up,
the biggest problem I
find with the young MBAs,
at first, the job is you shining,
raising your hand, having the answers.
They want to do that all the time.
They just got out of school.
They want to show you how smart they are.
Now, the transition to
manager, it all changes.
It's about growing your people, not you.
You grow from the reflected
glory of your people.
So it's all about making them flourish.
I like to use the line that your job
is walking around with a
can of water in one hand,
a can of fertilizer in the other hand,
sprinkling it on the seeds
and watching them grow.
You'll get some weeds, and you
got to pull those weeds out.
So everyone's not going to flourish.
But you've got to be
thinking about all the time,
loving to see your people thrive.
Loving to see them get promoted.
It's a real turn on.
It is what management's all about.
It's about bringing to people
great lives, great futures,
changing their family's life.
That's a turn on.
It's a big deal.
That's what you've got to think about.
When you work in a business
and you're asked to do something,
if you just do what the
boss asks you to do,
you will end up just confirming
what the boss wanted to have written down.
They already knew the answer
when they asked the question.
So your job in the new
job is to over deliver.
Give them new perspectives.
When anybody asks you,
schools ask you for a problem,
problem-solving and occassionally,
then they ask you the questions.
So you answer the questions.
You don't get the questions in business.
You have to develop a
perspective that's wider.
And I always tell the
story of my first job.
I was a project manager in
a little plastic operation
in Pittsfield, Mass,
and my boss wrote, from New York,
he was coming up to see,
not my boss, my boss's boss.
And they wanted me to come in
and wear one those white shirt pictures
to present the cases for my new plastic.
Tell him where I was going.
So I got all prepared.
But I did do is, I didn't
talk about my project alone.
I talked about the 10
plastics in the industry,
where they were going to be in five years,
their cost structure, from the DOW,
Silanes, Dupont, et cetera.
I developed that package.
And I gave my boss's boss
this picture of the industry.
I think that's how I got noticed there.
I got out of the pile because
I didn't just give him
my project report, here's
what I did yesterday,
here's what I'll do tomorrow,
here's what we'll do next day.
I gave him perspective,
and made him look smarter.
He now knew more about the
industry than he ever knew.
And that's what you want to do.
You always want to over deliver.
Never do what the assignment is.
Do more than that.
Wider, new insights, new horizons.
Well, if you're a leader,
you clearly have to demonstrate it.
You have to be open.
You have to be able to admit mistakes.
You have to be able to cut
through the business-ese.
You've got to be able
to talk to every person
in your organization in such a way
that they know where they stand.
No one can be a manager without,
no one can call themselves a manager
and have employees working for them
when the employees don't know
exactly where they stand,
where they are relative to others,
and where they're going in their career.
When you're debating a deal,
you've got to have an atmosphere
where everybody gets it on the table.
Not massive PowerPoint slides,
numbing chats that put people to sleep.
But really dialogue, face-to-face,
eyeball-to-eyeball confrontation
about why the deal works,
why it doesn't work.
And you demonstrate that yourself.
You, yourself, would be,
if the place is tied up in its knickers,
it'll be because you are
setting an atmosphere
that isn't open, isn't fun.
We used to make fun of
people that wouldn't be open.
You know, we'd josh about it,
just to try and lighten the
thing up so they'd get there.
Candor can kill you, though,
because candor, if you're
in a stiff, rigid hierarchy,
you've got to be able to use it right.
Because if nobody above
you is practicing it,
and you come in swinging from the fences,
it could be troublesome.
I happen to believe it speeds
everything in business.
It speeds decision-making,
it moves the organization
competitively faster,
it gets people to be open
about where they fit.
I was over at the BBC this week,
and this place is the most paralyzed place
I've seen in my lifetime.
(audience laughs)
Thousands of people are walking around
fighting to death about
what's going to happen.
Are they going to get sacked.
Every interview I had, they asked about,
"well, somebody here is
going to get sacked,"
while we're going through here.
And no one knew where they stood.
And so the management
there is just being cruel.
So employees are walking around
not knowing where they stand.
You can't have an organization
where people don't know,
you, as a professor of
organizational dynamics,
you know that you've got
to let people know where they stand.
They can't be in this
fight and paralysis state.
Nothing happens.
- Thanks so much for watching.
- We meet these people because
Ryan J Davis asked us to.
- So if you have a famous entrepreneur
you want us to profile next--
- Leave it down in the
comments section below,
and we'll see what we can do.
- Also, we love to know which one
of Jack Welch's top 10
rules meant the most to you.
- Leave it in the comments below,
and we'll join in the discussion.
- Thank you so much for watching.
Continue to believe,
and we'll see you soon.
(thunder sound booms)
- Differentiation is a big value of mine.
I don't believe you can run a company
without having an organization
that differentiates,
differentiates on how it
treats different businesses,
some are not equal,
and people, not equal.
Takes care of the stars,
motivates the middle,
and asks the bottom to move on.
I believe that.
You think the Patriots
keep the worst players?
Why should a sports team
The silliest thing that I hear
when we talk about differentiation,
and we get this all the time is,
how can you possibly be telling somebody
they're not that good and
somebody else is that good?
Well, why should you stop getting grades
the day you leave the U?
Why should a grown-up
not be able to grade,
but a sixth grader is
given best in the class,
and weakest in the class?
It's the dumbest idea in the world.
So you want to tell
people where they stand.
As a manager, people always
have to know where they stand.
You can't be turning away from it
and then one day going in and
saying we're having a layoff.
Now, when Ford has this big 30,000 layoff,
hopefully they got a
performance appraisal system
that somebody won't be saying, "why me?"
And somebody says, "well,
you weren't very good."
And they pull out the appraisals
that say they were great
for the last 10 years.
You want candor, you want differentiation,
and those are things I believe in.
I walked around GE preaching constantly.
Don't you ever think you're a victim.
If you ever feel like a victim, get out.
Because if enough of you get out,
we'll find out who's making
you feel like a victim.
It's your job to take responsibility.
Go find another game.
There's plenty of games here.
Unemployment's low here.
Go find something else.
Go on your own.
Do something.
But, Jesus, don't spend
most of your waking hours
feeling like a victim.
If you ever say some thing's
important in your organization,
you better put your best person on it.
Because your whole organization
is evaluating how important it is
by who you staff it with.
The biggest mistake CEOs make is,
"let me give you this big puffy speech
"about how vertical this is.
"Inventory terms are critical.
"We need to get our cash flow improved."
And then they hire Joe four
months from retirement,
to lead the effort.
And the whole place just goes into a yawn.
Joe is like a gas pain.
He'll go away.
And that's what happens to the initiative.
And so it's an enormous problem.
You say something's
important, staff it that way.
Follow up that way.
Close loop measure that way.
But I'm sure many of
you have had experiences
where people would articulate
the criticalness of an issue
and then put some okay player on it.
Only your best.